One.
If you think you got what it takes,
get the hell out there.
Don't put yourself a time limit.
Now some people say,
Eh,
if I don't do it in five years,
I'm going to quit or whatever.
So when I came out here,
it was all in,
you know,
if I said five years,
I wouldn't have been here.
I would have been back a in Chicago working at Motorola.
Who knows.
Uh,
so I family's always been really,
really key to my success.
Uh,
having people who are very supportive and my wife,
who's a huge,
huge reason I am doing what I'm doing.
I mean,
you,
you know,
to have a wife to deal with the life of a comedian on the road away from home a
lot,
and you've got to have like a strong,
strong woman to be in your corner to,
to put up with that.
Also just a deal with the Weirdo of fucking comics.
A weird person.
Yeah.
I mean,
just the,
just the mentality of a comedian is,
is,
is tough to be around.
Not Tough.
It's just,
you know,
we're always,
in our own heads sometime.
So,
yeah.
So to answer your question,
where do I go from here?
I don't know.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm enjoying doing some movies.
I just started dipping my toe in to some of these movies,
the green book,
which is out now,
and a nominated for some awards for the Oscars and happy to be a part of that.
And then,
uh,
I like it.
I exercising a different muscle,
um,
when it comes to acting,
but not comedic acting.
I liked the dramas.
Uh,
uh,
I,
I'm a serious guy.
Uh,
generally speaking,
I'm not a goof ball.
I'm not the guy always the center of attention and it's just not who I am.
So I like kind of being serious and,
and,
and acting in a drama kind of place to kind of who I am.
It's kind of a serious guy.
Uh,
and I like it.
I,
I get my fix from doing the stand up on stage.
I don't need to do it in a movie.
So I liked the challenge number one.
And number two.
Um,
uh,
I just liked to do different,
different things a little bit outside the box.
Um,
so I liked,
I liked doing it.
I mean,
did this gangster movie coming out with Scorsese and no shit.
Yeah,
it does that it's called the work with Scorsese.
Yeah.
So it's called the shit to Irishman.
What is it about?
It's about basically Jimmy Hoffa and how,
how they killed him.
This guy,
I have the narrow plays,
the Irishmen.
Jimmy Hoffa is played by,
but Chino,
pat,
she's in the movie,
so,
and I played crazy Joe Gallo.
Um,
and uh,
my first Dan,
the scent was with De Niro and Peshy.
So the fuck was that lie in that?
Yeah.
So,
um,
I was shitting.
I mean there's no,
who is that on the left?
Pachino get the fuck Outta here.
Wow.
That's incredible.
I mean,
maybe it's just that photograph,
but it,
that,
that barely looks like,
I know that,
uh,
this is coming out on Netflix.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
How different he looks.
Wow.
That's a Netflix movie,
Huh?
Fucking Netflix,
Yeah,
it's a,
it's like $145 million project and they,
uh,
it's coming out on October two.
What is enlightened to just being around Scorsese on a movie set and realize
you're a fucking actor in a Scorsese movie.
That's gotta be,
I mean,
that is about as high level as is.
It's like either Francis Ford Coppola,
Scorsese,
there's like a few people that you,
if you're on a set with them,
you know,
Kubrick,
when he was alive,
like,
Holy Shit,
that was a holy shit moment for me.
I was out,
listen,
I am by no stretch of the imagination,
a seasoned actor and then to get thrown into this group of people,
uh,
and,
and working with them.
I mean,
I gotta tell Ya,
there was a sense of doubt.
Like,
you know,
sometimes I,
should I be here,
shit,
you know,
this is,
this,
is this happening?
And then you know,
to do the scene with the narrow and Peshy.
It was almost like after the first scene,
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I should be here.
It's all the anticipation,
a leading up to the moment that is unfamiliar to you.
Then once you do it,
you feel like,
man,
that was all in my head and I made it sound like it was going to be,
you know,
cause I was thinking the negative too.
I always think,
oh,
I'm going to screw this up and this,
that's what motivates me.
I never look in the positive,
always come from a negative place.
But uh,
once,
once I did that first scene with them and they were,
these guys were more than helpful,
uh,
working with them.
I mean,
Scorsese,
when he came out it was friendly.
Nice.
You know,
it was,
it was encouraging to be around that kind of positive energy.
Did you have a hard time sleeping the night before?
Oh yeah.
I didn't sleep,
I don't think for the first week leading up to the scene.
Um,
because I knew it was going to be with De Niro and Peshy.
They took Gotham comedy club in New York City and they made at the Copa Cabana,
which I thought was fitting because Gotham comedy club is kind of where I did
all my standup in New York.
I didn't really do any other club,
but Gotham and then here,
Great Club,
Great Club.
[inaudible] brothers who run it are fantastic guys.
And uh,
they,
they stayed transformed the Gotham comedy club into,
uh,
the Copa Cabana and uh,
Don Rickles is played by Jim Norton.
Uh,
no shit,
I'm watching.
I'm watching him on stage with,
um,
it's just crazy and it's like perfect Rickles.
I'm just thinking about that.
He's perfect for that.
You really did a fantastic job.
Really,
really did a great even
smile is almost like Rickles ask.
Yeah,
they gave him
Ah,
oh,
that's fantastic.
Casting.
Great.
Wow.
I mean,
come on.
Slow.
The fuck else would be better.
You got to get them fat that they fattened him on,
fatten them up.
Did he give him makeup to fat number?
They make him eat,
made them,
I think they made him bald and they gave him a fat suit.
No Shit.
Wow.
So that's amazing.
I mean the Jim Norton's a guy known for what the 20 years and now I'm sitting
there watching him as Don Rickles in a movie.
It was just blowing my mind.
It just blowing my mind.
But uh,
this thing is going to be,
I can't wait to see it.
I didn't see any of the movie even when I was doing it.
I didn't even look at what I was doing.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I'm really excited to see what this thing looks like.
God Damn.
That's phenomenal.
What a milestone.
A movie with Deniro output Chino Joe Judge Pass.
She a fucking Scorsese film.
Harvie cartels.
Holy Shit.
By Bobby kind of allies in it.
It's Harvey cartel.
A lot of people never saw the bad lieutenant.
Did you ever see them out of the 10 I've never seen.
Oh my God,
look,
Harvey Keitel has been amazing in virtually everything he's ever done.
But the bad lieutenant is one of those movies that's so fucked up and so crazy.
And it was a about a bad cop,
like all fucking really bad co and a completely,
totally out of control.
But it is one of those movies where after it's over,
you know the credits roll and you're just sitting there trying to catch your
breath.
Just going to Jesus Christ.
What the fuck did I just watch?
There's a an eighties ah,
I don't know how Jackie was.
It says 93 but they remade it with Nicholas cage a couple of years ago to get
the fuck out of here with that bad.
It's not the same.
No,
I love Nicolas Cage,
but no,
you stick to drive in that Eleanor Mustang and gone in 60 seconds.
You can't be bad lieutenant you son of a bitch.
Nothing.
You're not a great actor,
but look,
it's just,
there's certain guys that take over a role and to do that again,
like here's one,
like say if they offered you taxi driver,
they say,
hey,
we're going to do taxi driver again.
You don't have to be like,
yeah,
good luck casting somebody else.
Get the fuck away from me with that.
I can.
You can't be,
you can't be Dinero in taxi driver unless you're deniro like possible.
That movie Cape Fear,
another one he nailed.
It's by,
by the way,
Kate fear was,
I think someone else was that character before.
I think Robert Mitchum I think played the same role that Deniro played.
But I didn't know that when I saw it when I saw it.
I just thought it's fucking deniro.
I 62 there it is.
Yeah.
But if they tried to do it today,
like get the fuck Outta here.
No,
no,
no.
You can't.
Especially taxi driver now you can't recreate that role with another actor.
No bad lieutenant.
Nobody's seen that.
Nicholas cage badly 10 and even Nicolas Cage probably didn't watch it.
It might've been like a Sikh.
Why don't know if it was a remake cause it's called port of call.
Like it's got an extension on the end of the port of call New Orleans.
It's called bad lieutenant port of call New Orleans.
Yeah,
I heard about that.
Yeah.
That's the Nicholas cage one to nine.
So they tried to piggy back on it or some shit like that.
Yeah.
But whenever that Harvey cartel version is,
Holy Shit,
but he's creating everything.
He was great.
And Pulp Fiction and he's great and everything.
Yeah,
he's a fantastic actor and they really,
I mean the people in this movie are,
what's it like hanging out with those guys?
I listen Joe,
when I went in there,
I told myself,
I ain't talking to nobody.
I'm going to speak when spoken to,
um,
there was a part when they were kind of lighting Deniro and I,
and were standing face to face and he's looking at me and I'm looking right at
him and I wasn't gonna say nothing.
And then he comes in and my,
my tiny tiny needs to be tight and a little bit and he cinched my tie.
Oh Wow.
Straightened out my,
yeah,
I had a wig.
They put me in a wig.
And what kind of wig would it look like?
Actually,
there's there,
there,
if you type up Sebastian Maniscalco Irishman that it should pop up.
Oh yeah,
there it is.
What is the difference?
I'm so confused.
Why did they give you a wig?
It's Scott sideburns.
I mean if you,
if you see it in person,
you'll understand maybe why I have,
yeah,
it's not that much of a departure from,
from my,
my real hair.
But,
uh,
did they give you the option to grow inside burns and you like it?
The phone?
No,
they just said it again.
I didn't say nothing.
They said you're going to wear a wig,
no problem.
Whatever you want me to do.
Scorsese was like,
um,
okay.
Um,
there's a part where I'm going to go through a window and he's like,
okay,
when you go through the window and I'm like,
oh,
I'm going to a window.
Cause I knew there was a stunt guy involved.
Right.
But he's telling me that I'm going to go to the window and I wasn't going to
say,
I don't do windows.
You want me to go to the window to a window.
I'm not gonna tell Martin Scorsese op,
sorry,
I need a stunt guy.
Um,
but then they said,
hey Marty,
there is a stunt guy here.
He goes,
oh,
okay.
So,
uh,
I was ready to go through the window.
I went through a window on news radio,
Nick Dipaolo through me through a window.
Is that right?
Yeah,
it's,
it's easy.
They're made out of sugar glass.
You just go right through it.
It's weird.
It feels like nothing like a tissue paper or something.
It's very strange.
I was like,
whatever,
whatever it,
whatever it takes.
Scorsese wants me to go through.
I mean the guy went through the stunt,
double went through and he cut his hand.
Oh,
did he really?
So I dunno what,
what it was.
Oh,
if I would've went through the window,
Joe,
I would've been dead.
He's such a cycle.
He might've made the guy go through real glass,
you know,
he might've been like,
this is just not realistic enough.
This,
yeah.
If 500 extra dollars,
this sugar glass,
whatever it is,
is not going to work.
But I guess you could probably cut yourself on that sugar glass shit if you
landed wrong.
I mean,
if it was sticking up wrong,
you placed your hand funny.
It makes sense.
Probably could cut yourself a little bit.
But yeah,
it was exciting.
It's been really exciting for me to last three or four years,
um,
to have these opportunities to do these things.
And,
um,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
that's great.